will get five random topics from all
around the room then we'll drop a beat
to a freestyle rack if you are sat
section number one what would you like a
rap about
you're not in that section but you stick
you set you shout out loud and proud
sea Parks I'm gonna Echo that man what
the [__]
he runs a startup and he was like I'm
gonna see if people know what my startup
is yes see Parks [__] no one's ever
heard of it
C Park I mean if I ask you what is it
I'm afraid you're just gonna say it's a
park in the sea
it
see trout
you're so far away the lag it's like
you're sat a mile away
are you from the 1910s when this was an
invention hey come down to Atlantic City
we've got sea Parks hey hey
[Laughter]
whatever the [__] a c Park is that's all
rapping about right um well we'll bounce
over to this this segment the room hello
what would you like a wrap up yeah hand
up there
tiny person a tiny like a borrower
like a tiny tiny per are you Irish why
are you putting on the accent then
a teeny tiny person a tiny one
where are you from
North Carolina fun fact people in North
Carolina Sound Irish when they say tiny
tiny person
a tiny tiny person cool uh front middle
of the room we'll come to you what your
rap battle
s puppies but a puppy's birthday party I
will accept that as an animal but it's
it's quite cute what what breed
caterpillar a Cavapoo
[__] every month there's a new
so that's a that's a poodle with a
a Cavalier what the [__] is that oh
wait literally you mean the King Charles
yeah we've still got our Insidious claws
everywhere
okay
okay a party for a Cavapoo puppy
uh C parks and a tiny tiny person
um let's let's come I mean we didn't
even get one from this section because
he said but back of the did you did you
shout chainsaw
yeah I will accept that because you look
like you've used a chainsaw
let me ask are you from New Jersey
[Laughter]
of course are you
[__] terrifying because I
maybe it was like no I'm from Maine I'd
be like oh trees but no bodies right
okay
chainsaw uh back back at the room let's
let's get this out
okay so so Cheesecake Factory what did
you add to it
vomiting in the Cheesecake Factory
excellent excellent device really yeah
my lovely band I'm blessed to have you
here I would love you to bless this
audience with your talents
[Applause]
let's see what we're gonna do they come
up with music I come out with a wrap uh
it will be as good as a suggestions the
suggestions were great
a high bar
yeah but we'll uh
freestyle bars off the Dome you know
I'll have a few back in the day a puppy
I was lusting for the Cavapoo you take
two the poodle that'd be smart second on
the dog intelligence chart but then a
hark A tiny wee stand your long brown
ears ever so lustrous in the locks come
here I make them get to [__] I have
to hold the smaller dog right on top of
poodle I know it's looking pretty odd
but now we celebrate it we're getting
yucky because they're eating all the raw
meat there I see my puppy face down he's
like yo this was no mistake apologies
it's not dog food it's cheesecake we're
at the factory I'm pushing it into its
stomach but appetite starts to plummet
now something be rumbling around start
knees shaking on the ground and I'm
hurling out my guts people vomit at the
sound we've been throwing up a
Technicolor flow Cheesecake Factory now
you'll never wanna go if you smell the
scent of vanilla I know you bows your
stomach it's just gonna spill out your
Gully you feel the burn like the acid
starting in your heart burn over here
some guy was smart and he was saying sea
Parks I know everyone knows the thing
I'm gonna say at the comedy show here I
go see Park Chris why are you not
backing me up you heard Sea Park this
guy was like what the [__] no one knows
what that is it's so pretty let me break
it down it's like an amusement park the
shitty oh just go into the Briny ocean
come on guys you can cause a lovely
commotion find a starfish there's no
slides there's just a rock pool and it's
slightly snide for you to say I hear
that guttural Roar rev rev room with my
lovely chainsaw see the little blades
moving round and round swirly twirly yes
of course I'm from New Jersey I'm
walking in shopping Lim from limb
everyone keep an eye on him he knows
where bodies are buried he loves to
attack it the mafia they prefer using
baths full of acid but you nah that's
not that [__] you start chopping them up
into tiny bits you'd be breaking them
down yes no rehearsing after you finish
with them they're a real [__] tiny
person
thank you